My name is Jonathan Keats and I am an
experimental philosophers.
What that means is that I do things like
open a restaurant for plants.
I sell real estate in the extra
dimensions of space.
I choreograph ballets for honeybees.
I build systems by which you can become
married by a law of nature using quantum
mechanics.
I even attempt to genetically engineer
God.
All of these are rather absurd on the
surface and me not seem especially
practical in your everyday life.
However,
I think that there are some basic
lessons that can be extracted from them
that at least for me are highly useful
even when I am not pursuing experimental
philosophy even when I am simply trying
to get by in the world.
Basic ways in which an experimental
philosopher looks at the world.
That can be divided perhaps into five
lessons and I'm going to go over these
with you.
By way of example,
looking at some of the projects that I
have undertaken with the takeaway that
you might be able to apply these rules,
either to undertake your own experiment
in philosophy or simply that you can use
these in your creative problem solving
at work or at home.
The lessons can be very briefly
summarized as follows,
ask naive questions,
invert perceptions,
combining compatible ideas,
remix metaphors,
and pursue paradox.
By no means are these comprehensive and
the rather Glib.
Yet I think that if you take these as a
point of departure as I sometimes do,
you'll find that you get outside of
yourself in terms of your routines,
your education,
and your common sense.
And you start to look at the world in
different ways that may lead you to
ideas that you never knew that you had.
And so I would like to invite you to
join me in this workshop in experimental
philosophy here on Big Pink Mentor.